good afternoon
my name is dr adam murphy and i'm
representing northwestern medicine and
i'm also on foot on faculty at cook
county health and jesse brown va
now i'm talking about genetics and
prostate cancer disparities facing
african americans
i wanted to highlight that the incidence
of prostate cancer is 78 higher
uh and men of african ancestry are not
hispanic black men
relative to warnings
uh this mortality disparity is more
stark with
african-americans having 230 percent
higher mortality rate
than whites and that's persisted over
the past
30 years of prostate cancer
including the psa screening area era
in 2017 the rate for the non-spending
black males was 36.8 for 100 000
compared to 17.8
and working months
this increased baseline incident
is associated with an increased
presentation at regional and metastatic
disease stage which is responsible for
about 76
of this mortality disparity many believe
that further issues with access to care
and quality of treatment received are
responsible for much of the rest of the
mortality disparity
several studies have now shown that when
black bay receives equivalent care
in the setting of clinical trials or in
the va
that the mortality disparity disappears
as we describe blacks have higher
incidents
twin studies from the nordic region
nordic region like finland and norway
and sweden uh suggest that the prostate
cancer
is 42 to 58
heritable meaning that 42 to 58 of the
incidents is also environmental
black men with prostate cancer present
about two years earlier on average and
have nearly six times the odds of
presenting with prostate cancer before
the age of 65 relative to whites
here present with regional and
metastatic disease more often
given the disparity in incidence and the
age of presentations that black men face
we would expect that the genetic burden
of prostate cancer risks loci would be
higher in men of african ancestry
including west africans
and african-americans
and that these genetic loci would have a
bigger impact on early prostate cancer
there's actually data from two recent
studies
one is by the johns edel and one is by
dr conti et al that explores the
incidents and age of facts
uh inherited variants in particular
genes like brecco 1 record 2 and hox b13
account for some cases of hereditary
prostate cancer
men with variance in these genes have a
higher risk of developing prostate
cancer and in some cases other cancers
during their lifetimes
in addition men with regard to our hex
b13 gene variants
may have a higher risk of developing
life-threatening forms of prostate
cancer
data from dr isaac powell and from dr
ruth etione using autopsy and seer data
suggests that the tumor progression rate
is faster in black men
that accounts for their higher mortality
rate there have been two recent studies
evaluating
known germline mutations
in
black men and in black women
in black men it focused on a thousand
metastatic prostate cancer patients
with 180 of them being black and 616 of
being white
and in females that were diagnosed with
breast cancer from the force study there
were 57 000 whites and 6 6700 blacks
the takeaway from these studies uh
are that
there were not higher
uh
risk of having established
pathogenic cancer variants for black
women or for black men
they were very similar to their white
counterparts
in both
prostate cancer and in breast cancer
and but there were a lot of variants of
unknown significance
for
black men and women higher than that for
white showing that these patient
populations are still under investigated
um it also shows that the most harmful
mutations were shared by black men and
black women
and other racial graves and those were
uh atm check two record one and beggar
two
there is remarkable similarity in the
disparity in survival that are shared by
all the ethnic minority groups and
although the one five and ten year
growth of
are hot for everyone
whites have higher
survival rates compared to all the other
ethnic groups which are remarkably
similar pointing to the fact that most
of the survival disparity
is probably from social determinants of
health
uh
blacks do have 2.3 times the mortality
rate of whites and this is exaggerated
in black men under age four four sorry
under age fifty three four times
mortality rate of weights
until recently guidelines
were recommending that all men begin
screening at age 65
without firm recommendations for black
men
i honestly believe that this policy
contributed to delayed detection for
black men
we may see a reduction in the mortality
this very over over time
because we may be screening it earlier
times
uh especially for young prostate cancer
patients when it's more lethal clearly
number one evidence is lacking but dr
yame
from uw recently modeled the age ranges
for psa screening
that would achieve similar mortality
reduction
and limit over detection
as it does in whites from age 55 to 69.
they found that the screening
recommendation
for black men
that would have the similar benefit
would be age 45 to 69.
so i believe that the focus of the
disparity investigation
for prostate cancer should be focused on
incidents
slash early age of diagnosis
and then delayed diagnosis is mostly an
issue of social determinants of health
and an issue in policies and research
punishes trying and attack that issue
the 22 established
uh snips that are associated with
aggressive disease are not
uh more elevated than black men also to
whites
suggesting that the focus should be on
the incidents
uh there are four autopsy studies
uh
that have been done in nigeria which is
the
most common essential population for
west
for middlewest african ancestry
in america or african-americans
these uh four studies
uh
go against the conventional wisdom that
the excess risk
of prostate cancer is from their west
african ancestry
we got to lead one because
uh we believe that prior autopsy studies
from
the west african region i had
were less than ideal because they would
oftentimes have
uh
longer time for people to be deceased to
be included
they didn't necessarily have
the same level of step sectioning to to
review
uh at five millimeter intervals
uh and
we wanted to make sure that there was
pathology consensus between
uh the nigerian and the american
pathologists to make sure that we were
grading similarly
we did this and this was published in
the process in 2021
we got representations from the major
tribes
in nigeria and they were mostly
recruited from lagos and calabar
overall we came up with only three
prostate cancers out of this 34 patients
which gave us a crude one-year
prevalence of laden or undiagnosed
prostate cancer of 8.8 percent
this
is actually really similar to the other
three studies crude prevalence rates
which were between 6.4 and 11.6
uh and this these octopus studies go
back to 1980.
even though our assembly cell is small
the remarkable consistency in prostate
cancer prevalence across these studies
indicates that prostate cancer may not
be as common in nigeria
as solved on the basis of cancer
registry data
though the
the frequencies of wrist snips
uh
are similar between west african men and
african-americans
this is from a meta-analysis of 19
autopsy studies i mean from the united
states and europe
and so for this the black
uh
represents u.s and
whites and european men
white europeans
uh the gray or the u.s blacks and the
white or a lighter gray uh
vars are are east asians
and this is uh talking about the
rate of prostate cancer on autopsy
across race
uh with over 6000 men involved what we
find is that the rates of latent
prostate cancer in american
and uk
uh whites is about 30
and it's about 48
for
blacks this is actually consistent with
ipals data which showed
a 64 percent crew prevalence in blacks
and a 48
uh prevalence in whites and those are
really well done studying
publishing the general neurology
in 2010 uh
that means that americans have
uh four to six times higher rate of
latent prostate cancer than
west africans and nigerians in
particular meaning that there's an
american disparity in prostate cancer
that is just worse than black lives
but to figure out what the red snips are
uh
people from uh
the multiple consortiums that chris
haynes put together uh have
done a large multi-ancestry g-wise
and didn't get a meta-analysis
and they
were able to identify 86 new wrist snips
associated with prostate cancer risk
uh and of course there are not all
candidate genes now that they've found
uh that they think are associated with
prostate cancer development
this is on top of the 183 previously
known
uh wrist snips
so they use the total which are 269 risk
variants to come up with a genetic risk
score
and then they use that risk score to see
what the predicted
risk of prostate cancer was in men of
european african east asian and hispanic
ancestry
and then they performed two independent
uh replications
uh in european ancestry and african
ancestry men
to validate its
accuracy uh looking at the lowest decile
of risk from this genetic risk score
uh
compared to average risk which is 40 to
60 percent
uh people in the lowers risk
very similarly had lower eyes of
prostate cancer diagnosis
and when you
look at the top one percentile of
predicted risk from the genetic risk
score
it meant that relative to average risk
they had
european estimate had almost 12 times
the odds of prostate cancer
there was only about 5.7
times the odds in
blacks
so i there may be more uh risks to
discover
uh in blacks a new loci or maybe that
the loss of the er that there have been
found need to be
uh searched in the same region for a
better predictive slip for african
ancestry men but the but overall genetic
restore works
if you limit the snips to those who have
an odds ratio greater than 1.1 for
increased risk of prostate cancer
diagnosis
we found that blacks had a slightly
higher frequency
of these higher risk snips
higher than all the other racial
ethnic groups
uh when they look at
the genetic risk or sniffs
to see if they're associated with low
risk or high-risk prostate cancer
they were equally associated with bugs
meaning that the genetic risk score
could not predict aggressive disease
again focusing it back on the incidence
of prostate cancer as a disparity
they did stratify the
their
sniffs by age to see where snips are
most associated with increased risk
by
uh age strata and most of the risk steps
that they identify
were in men who are younger than 55
there were few that were in that older
than 55 age range and almost all of them
are associated with increased risk for
prostate cancer not decreased
so my conclusions are that based on the
genetic risk score developed by
kante yet out on the on the
backs of or shoulders of other prior
work
blacks do have a higher distribution of
higher risk snips compared to other
ethnic groups which may explain their
increased incidence
uh
and
because these wrist snips were mostly
associated with
early prostate cancer before age 55 it
could explain their higher likelihood of
having
uh prostate cancer before age 65
uh and also the earlier age on that on
average
which is about two years
uh i think we need more gui studies
and we do studies in african ancestry
populations
to
to
further improve the genetic risk score
and to provide estimates of vascular
risk and to identify more causal alleles
to uncover the underpinnings of prostate
cancer
then i do think that focus should be on
the genetic predictions of rapids who
are progression and lethality in black
patients
these are my references
thank you for your time